Consider line 'p' and line 'q' which are on a plane.
The lines are also parallel to each other,
which would mean that they do not intersect or ever meet.
And this is transversal 'R' ,
which cuts the lines 'p' and 'q' at two distinct points.
In this video we will try to understand the different types of angles formed
by the transversal with two parallel lines.
The transversal forms four angles with line 'p',
angles 1, 2, 3 & 4. And four angles with line 'q',
angles 5, 6, 7 & 8.
Let's move on to the first type of angles.
If lines p and q are parallel, then angle 1 will always equal angle 5.
This angle here will be equal to this one.
They are called corresponding angles.
It doesn't matter how the transversal is placed.
These angles will always be equal.
On a new page let us try moving the transversal around.
Assume line 'a', and line 'b' are parallel to each other.
And here is a transversal 'c'.
You can see that these two angles look equal.
Now let's rotate the transversal towards the right.
These two angles again seem to be equal.
Now let's rotate the transversal towards the left .
The angles become obtuse and are still equal.
This tells us that the corresponding angles are always equal.
Now let's go back to the previous page.
Now let me ask you an interesting question.
Look at the figure closely.
Is this the only pair of corresponding angles?
No! It isn't. We have three more pairs of corresponding angles.
When a transversal intersects a pair of Parallel lines.
Four pairs of corresponding angles are formed.
Two and six form a corresponding angles pair.
So angle two will always equal angle six.
You can even look at the figure and observe that they are equal.
Similarly, angle three will equal angle seven,
and angle four will equal angle eight.
These are the four pairs of corresponding angles that are formed.
1 & 5, 2 & 6, 3 & 7, 4 & 8.
Angles 3, 4, 5 & 6 are interior angles,
because they are between the two parallel lines.
And they are classified into two types.
Let's understand the first type.
Angle 3 and Angle 5 form a pair of alternate interior angles.
We know why they are called interior,
but why exactly are they called alternate?
If we have a round table with numbers 3, 4, 5 & 6 around it,
then 5 is alternate to 3.
That's because after 3 you skip 1 position and take the next.
Similarly, 6 will be alternate to 4.
In this diagram as well
to find alternate of 3 we skip 1 position
and take the next which is 5 .
And similarly, angle 4 and angle 6 are also called alternate interior angles.
This was the first type of interior angles.
The second type is a pair in which
the angles are next to each other on the same side of the transversal.
Like angle 3 and angle 6. They are called consecutive interior angles.
Look at the figure now.
Do you see any other pair of consecutive interior angles?
Yes! With the same logic even angles 4 & 5
are consecutive interior Angles.
Remember, there are two types of interior angles.
Alternate and Consecutive. For alternate
we skip one and move to the next.
For consecutive, we take the one that's immediately next to it.
And the last types of angles that are formed are vertically opposite angles.
Angles 1 & 3 are called vertically opposite angles.
In all there are 4 pairs of vertically opposite angles,
Apart from angles 1 & 3, we have angles 2 & 4,
angles 5 & 7 and angles 6 & 8 as the other 3 pairs.
And vertically opposite angles are always equal.
These were the different types of angles that were formed
when a transversal meets two parallel lines.
On a new page let's look at the beauty of these angles.
Assume we have lines 'a' and 'b' which are parallel.
And transversal 'c' which intersects them at two distinct points.
As we already know the transversal forms eight angles.
One, two, three, four, five, six,
seven and eight.
Let us quickly analyze the relation between various angles formed.
It's pretty simple actually.
Angle two will be equal to angle six
as their corresponding angles.
An angle eight equals angle six
as it is vertically opposite to it .
And angle four equals angle eight because they are corresponding angles.
Similarly, angle one equals angle five as their corresponding angles.
Angle seven equals angle five because they are vertically opposite.
And angle three equals angle seven because they are corresponding angles.
So if lines 'a' and 'b' are parallel,
we can see that angles one, three, five and seven are equal.
And angles two, four, six and eight are equal.